[Music]
in over 12 years of working in IIT
industry I've worked on various domains
such as College Assurance manual testing
and technical writing I am planning to
move into product management domain
because I think it's a good career
choice I think it has become easier now
as I have taken the product management
course from Simply learn hey I am
saurabh Jain I live with my family in
Indore currently I am working as a lead
content writer at Rakuten Symphony I
lead a team of three to four people
there I've always been interested in the
management side of things that's why I
did my MBA in 2017 as a lead technical
writer I communicate with the product
team on a regular basis while doing that
I developed an interest in product
management I want to be part of creating
a product or enhance existing products
in the industry
I realized to do so I needed to pursue a
course I came across an ad on LinkedIn
espision name was associated with it I
really like the course I got to know
every my new detail about product
management the content and faculty
workers the core structure was also good
complex Concepts like product ideation
design thinking and Innovation were
taught during the course
and the faculty makes it easier to
understand all the concepts even for
those who have no prior experience I am
planning to change my domain to product
management within my company and it is
under discussion
I am able to understand the perspective
of the product team and give my inputs
with much more confidence
the course has also helped me develop
leadership and growth mindset it was one
of the things that was taught during the
course
a product manager is not only supposed
to interact with internal stakeholders
but with various other parties
I think I will be able to do it much
better in future in my free time I like
to write blogs play music and watch
inspirational movies
I believe we all are writing our own
story and learning new skills will help
you write your own success story foreign